how's the gum rose this is a banana
that's hilarious
let's get my name is Peter Pat let's
play heart of darkness are you ready to
finish this game all right I think I
know how to do it now we're gonna shoot
this guy [ __ ] up
then we're going to shoot this guy again
good double [ __ ] and three times
because [ __ ] can you stop [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] how do I shoot the one
behind him you're shooting the ceiling
wait wait a second there it is what do I
keep hitting the same one fairness
fairness I'm so [ __ ] focused there it
is Oh God
okay we got to be faster god this is so
complicated I'm sweating shoot him come
on shoot him eat this [ __ ] Hey you can
shoot diagonally I didn't even know that
okay now yeah stuck on these titties I
will show you but it's not a lot on
Twitch what the [ __ ] is this are those
mushrooms oh my god
why do I always get eaten
don't you dare oh my god can we just
stop god damn it oh my god I need coffee
[ __ ] me then just [ __ ] me go down that's
how I'm talking Oh God no no move the
[ __ ] control they didn't work God
[ __ ] yeah why is he piece of [ __ ] go
down yes
okay okay what do we do now run did we
do it do it do it do it yeah Oh fist me
daddy oh my god
the [ __ ] do I do Oh God I came to the
wrong hood that joke don't worry about
it
what do I do hi guys what's up fellow
gangsters what up fellow kids what are
you guys doing over here what's up you
guys want to do some crack cocaine
alright then how much do you want to bet
I'm gonna die jump over the water -
creeper go for it what the [ __ ] I was
reading the shot oh I'm still here I'm
still here thank you look thank Lord
okay
that was Laura de Lurkey sponsor ego
alright cool I got you eating my little
pieces of [ __ ] huh Oh eat me what is
that [ __ ] walnut oh oh I know what to
do here I know that today have rest no
thanks to you breast sorry I love you
breast uh the stump you're right it's
not the stump [ __ ] I know you think it's
the stump but look what we need to do
here nailed it nailed it you see that
[ __ ] boom nailed it alright okay maybe
maybe this is them maybe you're right
I'm trying to hit the little nipple
that's floating in the water like what
do i do come on you're a mning at it
oh oh oh hey hey hey Oh goddamn it what
hey what's up ladies sucker
aah oh [ __ ] the scared me goddammit
that's not how you do a long gem goddamn
it fast I don't [ __ ] know oh god
don't kill me
nevermind Oh swim like a [ __ ]
ass licking pieces - [ __ ] God suckle
nice titties oh my god oh my god that
was painful
but we did it
alright
shot your [ __ ] riding ass [ __ ]
suck on this see you later
Bubba [ __ ] that's right that's right
that's how it's done
hey what's up all right can't wait for
something else to kill me I can't even
go there jump down jump down no jump
down mate mate mate jump down jump down
oh oh there's a rock here I'm pushing
the rock and Jennifer hit fit the hole
how do i how do I do this don't kill me
I know have a great ass
look at him just staring down at my ass
you love Syd I do have a new touching
thank you for noticing um how do I hit
him this is not gonna work out is it huh
oh my god yeah oh god I'm dead
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] damn it please don't put
me back at the start please don't put me
back at the start you mother [ __ ]
boom oh [ __ ] I gotta hit him too
that's how it's done coconut [ __ ]
Oh God go up okay go up go up go up go
up go up go oh yes suck on these alright
just gonna go just gonna go just gonna
go oh my god ah [ __ ] that stop stop god
dammit oh hey come on why you stop hey
you want some you want this ass Oh Oh
skip bagging it yeah that's right I like
it
hey baby you want to look get in on this
action but baby has weird fetishes oh my
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm charging my fireball I
can't move I'm a charging pit pit pit
pit pit pit down outta me now burn oh my
god the [ __ ] just happened
hey you want some
hey come on come on come on you want
some you want some be hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] come on man come on
you want some or what you want
good
no oh god you don't ha ha ha ha ha meet
Aubrey yeah vlieland ah ah it's already
have little looks pretty sore care the
[ __ ] is that name oh my god all right
everyone just [ __ ] jail all right no
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] got shoot hot
shoot ah no no shoot ah ha
Chirac ah no don't touch me [ __ ]
God got you now [ __ ] under hood net ha
oh oh no that's my [ __ ]
you want some of this some of this oh my
god oh my god did we do it hello is
anybody up there
hello we should probably crawl for
safety the well how about that
[ __ ] how about that you looking
at [ __ ] baby either you got him that's
right
[ __ ] nail that [ __ ] baby all right so
how do I go down now let me go down to
[ __ ] it down come on baby baby just stop
stop [ __ ] humping them oh my god why
did that not work before oh my god we
could have done this 84 years ago I hear
waterfall darkness that literally looks
like a butthole that had Chipotle um all
right well I guess all right thank thank
you for us thanks we did it I should
celebrate right we did it Hey how about
uh how about I have no you know what
[ __ ] you I'm just kidding all right Jess
just type it in the shed I don't give a
[ __ ] okay what do I do here left or
right it's been 84 years since Peter
Piper ogress in this game
I can't wait to get out of this area Oh
God where are we going now no what the
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] kidding [ __ ] me right [ __ ]
now are you [ __ ] serious with me
right now what do I do now cuz I ain't
doing that [ __ ] again twice alright
swim left after the rock Falls someone
said swim left after the rock fault
it's very interesting that you would say
that because that's what you should have
[ __ ] told me hello it's a hair on
that banana don't suck bananas on life
streams it will be awkward suck it in
private I mean if it is so packed I
swear to God my twitch monologues are
the worst [ __ ] thing they make myself
cringe and that's never a good thing
alright I'm just gonna go with the flow
as the ladies saying um bro jobs listen
I would show you guys my tit is butt
twitch wouldn't allow it
alright where's the boulder that
everyone's [ __ ] talking about that oh
hey hey hey hey what the girls swim like
the wind
no go up go up oh my god oh whoa [ __ ]
man
oh I'm just joking about twitch not
allowing me showing my nipples it's
really my said that wouldn't allow it
oh my god did I just walk past him oh my
god oh my god that is the most casual
thing I've done in my entire life Jesus
Christ
Oh Oh No oh I can't handle the [ __ ]
pressure right now oh my god seriously
please stop okay
gonna pick up the controller now and
we're gonna do this oh it's there they
chord praise lord gaben praise Him oh oh
my god
you want some of this oh that was
literally my penis right now except all
the awkward warts and stuff I don't I
don't have that I promise all right save
yeah I'll say
good good point I'm saving in-game that
ignore that text that's that's a glitch
I bought the game all right thank you
brush thank you thanks for reminding me
the same all right
gonna do some push-ups and then we're
gonna get into this [ __ ] okay all right
well I'm not gonna cheat all right
let's send don't tell me to stop
screaming
sometimes in video games it gets intense
what do you [ __ ] you one minute away
about fairness there it is
all right we got this huh No No thank
you for watching his livestream it's
been a pleasure thank you
oh it oh thank gosh okay fine I'm gonna
continue I thought it was gonna reset I
wasn't actually gonna quick no what are
you talking about I said nothing did
someone say quitting I never quit in my
life I've never quit anything in my life
never quit anything I was not gonna quit
I was I was ready to fight on because I
never give up on your brats you bros are
here for me and I want to be there for
you why didn't he just jump like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] thank you minecraft
minecraft' all right we did it
all right haters never quit and haters
never wait all right whatever there's a
saying there but it doesn't matter all
right so now what do we do yeah you're
right it's not the ninja way I am doing
push-ups I don't know what to do how
dare you you're god damn boy don't jump
too far oh my god
dumping too [ __ ] far what pick it up
with your dick
oh my god I can shoot it there okay oh
my god I pushed it and then it floats Oh
cuz we caused the stream from before I
should have realized that okay so now
we're gonna shoot the B button I hope I
don't die now don't fall in the water oh
there it is
Oh neigh ah so funny helmet as jävla rub
feet eq fairness are we actually gonna
progress oh my god I think we are I
think we're progressing right now holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy SH holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh my god look at that
face you look like my next mistake
loves a game wanna play how do I do this
thing I've too many acorns I'm not gonna
say browse all right I will say when the
game allows me to save no I'm not a
little [ __ ] I ain't gonna say that's
cheating
okay here we go can I shoot from the
vine I think I can like Tarzan side
[ __ ] okay we can hey that'd look pretty
cool oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god [ __ ] this banana alright okay
alright I feel pumped I feel like we can
do it it's literally 50/50 with a
[ __ ] jump alright alright here we go
come on show my nipples come on
you can do this job it's easy so easy
come on
I am nervous I'm sweating my throat
hurts cuz I've been screaming so much
but this is say alright this is [ __ ]
it I'm not pulling any more [ __ ] [ __ ]
after this all right here we go
oh yeah I can't believe we did it
I can't believe we did I feel like Leo
accepting the Oscar finally finally to
happen now I'm just gonna talk about
them I want to take the opportunity to
talk about the environment and what is
going on here how are we not done with
this area all right I'm gonna do a save
here and it looks like we're gonna have
to end it now that our episode there but
if you enjoyed please leave a like and
I'll see you bros in the next video and
as always stay awesome okay we're gonna
what the [ __ ] is this I got [ __ ]
stuck yeah dammit
oh my god okay all right time to focus